[Music]
good morning good morning well I wish it
was a good morning what did I ask you to
come into work today
what did I say was the one thing I said
to you come in as a but a boss right now
you look like a towel boy
I mean sunglasses around your neck badge
on their shorts on their who are you
give me the name badge
[Music]
stand out from the crowd you're the
owner I've had a really rough night and
serves my team get out of here get
changed and come back like an owner no
[ __ ] off ready honestly going up no no
no no no I'm not listening Gordon I'm
coming back like a boss I'm ready to
make this whole Fort Pierce community
prep Gordon get out of here seatbelt on
no doors no seatbelt oh my god I'll be
back I'll be back I'll be ready
[Music]
Rosen frozen frozen why are not even
wrapped
where are the burgers I mean it just
doesn't look anything like a burger that
weighs processed like that and stamped
impress you can just tell right Wow
Brett come with me yeah how's the
fettuccine not the best I'm sorry I'm
burgers a burger cooked here locally
would you expect that to be frozen or
fresh the burger is not frozen
it's the patties and everything come in
frozen when we thought out is that like
Mario people before elf
so it's not the frozen that it comes in
frozen yeah you thought out and that to
the your customers it's not frozen
burger well stay there let me just show
you that you don't waiting for him to
come back he's gonna ream me on
something oh boy here we go
mm-hmm so there's your burgers is it
frozen thank you well you husband said
it wasn't know what I mean no it's it's
frozen of course I never said that it
wasn't it we thought out here it comes
in frozen yeah it's still a frozen
burger there's no such thing as a fresh
burger at least at least here in Eastern
Washington we cannot get fresh there's
no proof do you find me the burger
[Music]
what a mess
wheels are stuck it was just sliding on
the [ __ ] grease it's gross Brenda you
got two seconds sure just stand behind
there with it please stand behind there
I'm I'm what is this
Maceo you guys just clean this and this
from today I don't even know what's back
there for render watts when was that
cleaned it's just two days ago they've
got spilled everything there come in I
know
handled ha that is not from yesterday
that is not from yesterday what's that
on that
what's your eyes what's your eyes who
cleans this [ __ ] who is it
there's that man here no one's clean
since you've been here no one's clean I
appreciate your honesty Miranda yes
since he's been here he's never cleaned
it this place is disgusting and this
I don't do this you guys clean the floor
the other day didn't you
we cleaned the line the other day we
sweep the line you said you fights to
power I'll never say that now if you're
just trying to make excuses yes you are
aren't you embarrassed
Barry at least you taught the [ __ ]
truth the owners in denial that has been
pulled out for [ __ ] months my god
welcome to him he didn't last very long
did it
found our cat oh bloody hell
dead cat like cabbage welcome nice to
meet you always good to see you too
golden first name is Melissa Melissa
good how are you Lisa croc Lisa nice to
see you've got no very happy I do
it's my resting face Wow yes welcome to
the Vienna it's not happy to be here
well I'm sure the cat food cat got run
over oh I see you got it stuffed all
right actually better to see you right
Sam yeah love the Attar by the way thank
you everyone wears this wow how much are
the outfits about 300 $400 $300 a bridge
you know they get their own I mean there
are their own dresses you know
oh you buy your own uniforms yeah stop
heads we do them for many years and it
reminds them to not gain weight Wow so
who designed the place well my husband
and I and whose idea was it to buy it uh
my husband she said wasn't the awesome
it was not my ideas actually very much
against it Wow why are you against it it
was very overwhelming I had two small
children but probably after I lost my
mind the first year
I think we started to get a hang of it
I'm who's Austrian are you my husband's
a Austrian or polish right I'm not
nearly as exotic I'm very American right
and he's the chef right so he runs the
restaurant kitchen and you run the inn
correct and whose idea was the violins
on the table mine
where'd that come from that was actually
from an estate sale down the street a
dead man's violin yes why not
I don't assert across the table with my
wife and look at dead man's violin well
bit freaky no no what would you rather
look at when you see the Vienna huh
who's hurt my wife Oh your wife yes yeah
but you have to have something to make
up that white space so what would you
suggest my wife you're gonna put her on
the table
that's what I'm a scandalous I am so
[ __ ] confused dead man's violin what
about some flowers order french bread as
a nap all right is that their sports
bowl or these TV screens one of those
microwaves
how many microwaves if he goes for here
in one in there at five there's one in
there I'm two chefs two chefs oh my god
what turn that's just junk everywhere
well this is cooking stuff just no no
we're cooking something no that's okay
how does this kitchen function give me a
little tour it's very challenging very
very challenging well sign that that's a
burger get on heating up boys
yeah you're boiling a burger I'm just
heating it back up we say he's me back
up why are you cooking it from fresh
we'd make them another time this is what
we got here we don't a bold burger are
you where the burgers are boiled ah
no do you think your customer will want
a burger boiled in water they seem to
like them